thank you Greg thank you Gunnar those
are beautiful things to say pat was also
making fun of you both probably so I I
want to thank the city of Hillsdale I
don't know if there's anybody here from
the city but they let us build a little
nearer Oh highland city managers here
there we're going to build this a little
nearer the street than is normal and it
makes it so there'll be a really great
entryway grateful to you for that I
think the people from Rockford I think
mr. pee-wee who's going to oversee them
and I think the clarence earl families
come to find out i knew that those were
great families before i knew any member
of them and the reason is i'm lucky to
know for a long time now don rumsfeld
who ran GD searle for eight years i
think in the late 70s and to the mid 80s
and he's a very great man he's actually
speaking at an event for the college in
in dearborn in two weeks and he is one
of the best sharpest people I know and
he's got this interesting career he was
in public service you know in very high
places and my report from good authority
ronald reagan came within an inch of
asking him to be his running mate in
1980 in the history of the country would
be different if he had done that thing
better I think and I one night I had a
long talk with Don Rumsfeld I've had
many I'm glad to say dong Roswell is a
significant donor to the college by the
way and he's giving us money that he
made running GD searle and so those
people are all over this place these
days and I said to him what was that
like I said running that company and he
said well it was unusual he said I don't
think corporate life is normally like
that and I said why and he said that
family is just great and I mark that
down and remembered it and it was years
later that I met any
body from that family and I thank them
and thank them for what they are what
they've done the brilliant Sally Clark
somebody had the good sense to ask her
what we should say about her parents so
I've struck out about two-thirds of it
because it's only important that I know
it according to Sally louia says I think
that Hillsdale College thinks outside
the box and I think the Searle family is
also a group not to follow the normal
paths that families tend to take the
Cyril family strives to be good citizens
but will fight the establishment if
their freedoms are taken away the family
works to keep its business in
philanthropy at a grassroots level not
just leaving these things to pay
professionals hillsdale also runs on
personal relationships
Sally says that Louise's father her
grandfather sorry Louise's yeah father
Sally's grandfather liked and respected
our College the sural mean the Clark
ildren I've now met all of them I think
and the three of them are here today and
they're all they don't like this right
they but I'm gonna say it anyway my
children don't like it either they are
all alike there's some character and
some stubbornness in them and thank you
as we're thinking why would we need to
build a big old dining hall it looks
like that it's not for the students used
to be the students dining hall it's not
wasn't really very good for that for
various reasons although it was
serviceable and thank God for it because
we're we've done what we've done without
it but what soon as we could we built
something with better acoustics and
higher ceilings and more light and
better capacity and now that's there and
so students are not really needed they
don't need that row and that that room
is going to hold 800 people thousand
about 800 yeah I always ask mr. pee-wee
he knows and who's going to come there
why are they going to come there because
you know our town is not very big I
don't know if it ever has a banquet with
800 people in it the answer is they're
going to come from everywhere they do
now last year on the campus 7,000 people
came to visit and the reason it wasn't
12,000 as we don't have any room we need
to expand the hotel space the campus we
need the auditorium to get bigger we
need to build our chapel for which we've
been given half a gift we need to build
some space around here for people who
want to live near tent near the campus
so they can build some places we need
all that and why do we need all that
because is you know we who live here
know it's dang cold up here
and the shopping is not very good the
searles are michigan people and Sally
said to me she said dad I think she's
just from Naples just been there and
she's going to the Bahamas tomorrow is
that right and she said I said it's a
hard life and she said somebody's got to
do it all right why are all those people
who are coming here why aren't they
going there instead well you heard the
answer what both the Greg and Gunnar
talked about is what they've learned
here you know what I value about my job
the most single best thing I learned a
lot and I don't mean by that the
excitement of lots of variety and
knowing lots of curiosities there's a
certain kind of thing a person can know
and that thing tells you what you are
and what you are to do and anything that
has that quality and there are so many
things like that in the American story
this facade is going to look like the
front of central hall and I was saying
in their central hall was dedicated on
the fourth of July in 1853 and that's
not because it was thursday and the
facade the front of central hall is in
the italianate Renaissance style which
is a derivation of the Federal style
from the fat from the founding of the
United States and that isn't an accident
either and so when they started this
institution of learning this second
president of the college made a speech
we have the text to it it's very lovely
there's no one could improve on it
certainly I cannot and it's about the
Declaration of Independence and there's
something beautiful about that thing
isn't there my brother-in-law is a
Hungarian honky as I call him and did
you know that in the Hungarian
Revolution of 1956 the year that his
family fled the country and he
came here that the last thing taken by
the Soviets that shut it down and think
about the riu crane today think about
what's going on there think about the
fact that two months ago students were
streaming into a square to be shot and
the last thing they broadcast on that
radio they had it on a loop was a
reading of the declaration of
independence do you see what it means if
there are laws of nature and of nature's
God it means that you could know them
and if you could know them you would
have the capacity to guide your life in
their direction so gunner friend got her
wonderful man gunner and a working
colleague gunner I know gonna really
well now and so he reminded me when I
was about to go over and say hi to
selling that I should say hi to Becca
too because becca didn't come to this
college and she's proud of it and she
thinks we forget about her now why did i
disclose that to you because it shows
something gunner loves Becca and he
would not want me to forget her even
though i know sally really well and that
means the gunner is occupying the
station of a father and that is like
having the dominion of a monarch he
bears the responsibility for these
children they ask him things he must
give them answers if something happens
to them he will be devastated he mustn't
live their lives for them proud that
they're independent I mean to the point
of cussedness by the way proud of that
doesn't want them anything to do
anything except excel and grow and be
great and tend to them and watch them
and long for them to do that all his
life
I'm not just finishing a book about
Winston Churchill and the socialist took
over toward the end of Churchill's
career and he fought them all his life
and by the way he entered Parliament the
same year that the socialist party was
born and in the third to the last
election he ever fought they overwhelmed
him and set up the first socialist
government terrible disappointment a
failure in his life and he just kept
fighting against it and he got a huge
opportunity because there was a minister
in the socialist government by the name
of Douglas J and here's what he thinks
and by the way read the newspaper and
you will see this everywhere he said
there's a lot of expertise now about
child nutrition and so mothers don't
really know as well as experts and train
people know what their children should
eat the gentleman in Whitehall Whitehall
is the name for the governing center of
Britain the gentleman in point of all
know better you see what that means
Cleves back there you know his third
kids come in here next year and this is
third kid like the first two are among
the best tennis players in Ohio in high
school and we don't even have a tennis
program and all through it for group for
boys anyway all three of those kids made
really top scores their Sydney hi Sydney
and the thing is Cleves dies for those
kids to come here but more than that he
dies for them to be well and what if it
were true that some trained expert was
better qualified to raise the delt
children or the klar children or the
sural children or the arm children than
we their parents because that is the
doctrine and that doctrine is coupled
with the idea that what we have
discovered is that there are no
such things as the laws of nature and of
nature's God there's only expertise now
and because that can be centralized than
the control over everything can be
centralized and we reach the answer now
why would people come and stay in that
place they come to behold the beautiful
things in respect to which they are
qualified to live fully human lives as
mothers and fathers and husbands and
wives and grandparents and daughters and
sons as entrepreneurs as people who make
their living and guide their lives and
raise their families and we find that
thing's beautiful that help us do that
those are the things that move us to
tears now there's a great motion under
way here in this little place it's very
strange it's the largest thing of its
kind in the college world by provable
numbers in recent memory anywhere in the
nation what's causing that what made
them you know because we talk about the
things we want to do we almost never
asked anybody for money at Hillsdale
College and I never asked on her klar
for the money for this he heard and he
saw and he perceived with the same
salted years talk he didn't I don't know
anything he doesn't know and he said
this is a fine thing let us assist
that means by the way that the love of
the good and the beautiful is a
compelling force and wherever it rises
it produces overwhelming results and we
are sitting amidst those results right
now and we are watching them unfold and
that is happening in an age where there
is every attempt to destroy is the word
to diminish to eradicate them with a
power that claims to make everything
perfect so think of the commitment we're
saying no to that and that means we're
prepared to stand in its way and it is
powerful and it will seek to run over us
let it try we will win our honor and
serve our good and our God in resistance
to it thank you